Друзі, сьогодні я познайомлю вас з роботою німецьких вогнеборців.
Сирена тривоги пролунала у професійній пожежній частині номер один міста Бонна.
Таких професійних пожежних частин у всій Німеччині - лише 110.
Натомість в десятки разів більше, а саме - 23 тисячі добровільних пожежних частин.
Добровольці мають іншу постійну роботу і займаються гасінням пожеж безкоштовно.
Професійні частини у ФРН організовуються у містах із населенням понад 100 тисяч людей.
Населення Бонна 320 тисяч людей, площа міста - 141 квадратний кілометр.
Аби краще зрозуміти логіку розташування пожежних частин, пропоную поглянути на місто з висоти пташиного польоту.
Окрім шкіл, дитсадків, лікарень, житлових та офісних будівель на адміністративні кордони Бонна припадає автобан,
залізничні та трамвайні колії, автотунель і 18 кілометрів річки Рейн.
Професійні вогнеборці виконують також обов'язки рятувальників,
тож усі транспортні шляхи включно з Рейном - їхнє місце несення служби.
У Бонні 5 професійних пожежних станцій, на яких працюють 360 вогнеборців,
і 18 станцій пожежних добровольців, на яких працюють майже удві більше людей.
Професійні частини розташовані неподалік старого центру міста та автобану, біля університетської клініки.
Волонтерські станції є у найменших центральних та віддалених районах міста.
Бонн ділять на сектори відповідальності таким чином, аби пожежна команда прибула на місце виклику максимум за 6 хвилин.
Професійні вогнеборці у Німеччині - це муніципальні службовці, державні службовці відповідного міста або муніципалітету.
Кожен пожежник та пожежниця проходять навчання на рятувальника і можуть надавати першу медичну допомогу.
Наш реанімобіль саме повернувся з виїзду. Тепер він очікуватиме наступного виклику.
Заходимо в гараж. У цієї пожежниці-рятувальниці закінчилася 24-годинна робоча зміна.
На спині у жінки - рюкзак для надання першої допомоги.
Мушу визнати, що здивований, адже досі я вважав, що реанімобілі базуються тільки у лікарнях.
Виявляється ж, лише у цій пожежній частині п’ять реанімобілів.
Наприклад, стався нещасний випадок на роботі.
Тоді до місця пригоди виїжджають ці машини, надають першу допомогу і доставляють пацієнта до лікарні.
Ось тут шафи з різноманітними витратними матеріалами, електрокардіограф, апарати штучної вентиляції легенів.
А це - рюкзак для невідкладної допомоги з усіма необхідними медикаментами.
Навчання на парамедика триває три місяці, потім він має право водити це авто та надавати допомогу пацієнтам на місці пригоди.
Друга спеціальність - фельдшер.
Він є керівником групи, на нього навчаються три роки,
здобуваючи значно бльше практики в лікарнях та рятувальних командах.
Окрім парамедиків та фельдшерів є ще лікарі найвищої кваліфікації. У цій пожежній частині два спецавтомобілі для них.
Лікарі швидкої, які працюють в лікарнях, мають також зміни і у нас.
Вони задіяні 24 години на добу, і їх у нас чергує троє.
Коли трапляються важкі випадки з багатьма пораненими,
ці лікарі також виїжджають на місце і керують процесом порятунку.
І медикам, і вогнеборцям від сигналу тривоги до моменту посадки в авто у повному спорядженні треба вкластися у 90 секунд.
Аби виконати цейнорматив, спускаються металевими 5-метровими стовпами з кімнати відпочинку одразу до гаражу, оминаючи сходи.
Франк Френзер завбачливо заправляє штани у чоботи,
щоб під час тривоги можна було відразу "застрибнути" в спорядження. Спробую скласти норматив.
Я їду, їду!
Підвели вузькі чоботи не мого розміру, треба ще тренуватися.
Мої колеги-пожежники вже поїхали, а я ще вдягаюся.
Ну що, друзі, схоже, що я готовий!
Франк, і за скільки я впорався? Три хвилини замість 90 секунд!
У день мого візиту до центральної пожежної частини Бонна за добову зміну
було 10 викликів для надання медичної допомоги і один виклик на пожежу.
За річною статистикою, лише 7 відсотків усіх викликів вогнеборців - на пожежу,
63 відсотки - для надання медичної допомоги і ще 22 відсотки викликів - технічна допомога.
Професійні пожежники працюють за спеціальним режимом.
Наша робоча зміна чергування триває 24 години з 7 ранку до 7 ранку наступного дня.
Потім ми маємо 48 годин на відпочинок. Тобто день працюєш - два дні вільний.
Я б не сказав, що мені важко працювати, так, бувають напружені моменти, однак особисто мені робота приносить задоволення.
Ну що ж, друзі, давайте подивимось, а що ж всередині пожежного авто.
Коштує така машина 300-400 тисяч євро.
Тридцятиметрові пожежні шланги. Загалом кабіна розрахована на п'ятьох людей.
А у кабіні водія розміщується ще й керівник команди. Загалом виходить семеро.
Як тільки вогнеборці сідають, ось тут вмонтований в сидіння рюкзак, у цьому рюкзаку є запас кисню на 30 хвилин.
Ось дивіться манометр на якому можна контролювати запас кисню.
О, а це знаменитий надувний пожежний матрац 5 на 5 метрів.
Ну і, звичайно ж, дві тонни води з собою.
Середня зарплата професійного вогнеборця з 5-річним досвідом сягає двох з половиною тисяч євро після сплати податків.
Добровольці, нагадаю, гасять пожежі безкоштовно, лише у виняткових випадках отримуючи премії за свою роботу.
А от вимоги до професійності і для службовців, і для добровольців - однакові.
І одні, й інші проходять навчання у пожежних училищах. Тривалість підготовки пожежників - 2 роки.
Загалом у Німеччині близько 60 тисяч професійних вогнеборців та один мільйон триста тисяч - добровольців.
Пожежна станція добровольців у районі Бонна Ланнесдорф.
Зараз відбувається традиційна щомісячна перевірка обладнання.
Інґа - професійна пожежниця і має свої робочі зміни у Дюссельдорфі, а мешкає у Бонні.
Тут у свої вільні дні вона допомагає як пожежниця-волонтерка.
Хоча сьогодні неділя, Інґа - на станції. Разом з іншим добровольцем - Бйорном, основна робота якого - водій автобуса у Кельні,
жінка перевіряє справність кисневої системи.
Коли стається виклик, він приходить пожежникам-добровольцям ось на такий пристрій.
Там вже вказано, що сталося та куди нам треба їхати.
Якщо в цей час я на роботі і, наприклад, працюю он в отій аптеці,
то маю бігти в пожежну частину, вдягати уніформу, застрибувати в авто і їхати на місце виклику.
У Німеччині заведено так, що попри це на основній роботі я все одно отримую повну зарплатню за місяць.
Місто компенсує гроші роботодавцю.
Усі, хто прийшли на зміну сьогодні, тут лише заради перевірки обладнання.
Зазвичай добровольчі пожежні станції стоять порожні й зачинені.
Пожежники прибувають сюди, лише отримавши повідомлення на пейджер.
А це уніформа юного пожежника, яка всім трьом знайома з дитинства.
У нас є об‘єднання юних пожежників, куди можна вступати з 10-річного віку.
Там у формі гри знайомлять з професією. Місто організовує цілі чемпіонати юних пожежних команд.
З 18 років зі своїми друзями і подругами можна вже навчатися цьому професійно.
Мені 30 років, моя основна робота - менеджер з продажу.
З 10 років я відвідую пожежну частину.
В дитинстві моєю мотивацією були величезні червоні машини, пофесійне обладнання і можливість цікаво проводити час з друзями.
Тепер я теж тут проводжу час з товаришами, до мотивації додалося відчуття
командного духу і те, що ми робимо корисну для суспільства справу.
Вражає те, що вогнеборці-волонтери мають обладнання, нічим не гірше за устаткування професійних команд.
Усе це фінансує місцева влада. Ян демонструє, як потрібно доодягнутися в кабіні по дорозі на виклик.
До місця пожежі вже треба вийти з підключеним кисневим балоном.
Вага усього комплекту обладнання 15 кілограмів.
Є і ось такий тепловізор, аби через стіни бачити місця займання. Бйорн пропонує проїхатися районом.
Звичайно, нам можна перевищувати швидкість, однак не екстремально, бо я відповідальний за всю команду у кабіні.
Перед перехрестям керівник групи, який сидить поруч, вмикає сині мигалки та сирену,
він контролює цей процес, а я маю міцно тримати кермо обома руками.
Поки я знімав відео, мешканці району підходили вітатися до пожежників.
Було видно повагу в очах дорослих і цікавість в очах дітей.
Добровольці у цьому районі - справжні супермени, бо опікуються не лише вогняною стихією.
Ще три дні тому тут була набережна: гуляли люди, бігали діти. Тепер все під водою.
Традиційно у лютому Рейн виходить з берегів і подолання наслідків водяної стихії - це теж задача пожежників-добровольців.
Ну, і як же без класичних випадків порятунку кота з високого дерева,
косулі, яка застрягла в паркані та всіх інших халеп, з яких можна визволити,
наприклад, ось такими гідравлічними ножицями.
Друзі, пишіть, що ще вам цікаво знати про Німеччину
і я спробую розповісти про це в наступній серії. Нехай щастить!